ciao mariners e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo video video super importante
adesso capirete perché ho appena
comunicato su instagram questa cosa che
è successa è visto che tanti di voi non
hanno instagram mi sembrava doveroso
condividere questa notizia anche con voi
partiamo proprio dall'inizio andiamo a
step
tutto è nato da un tatuaggio composto da
due parole che io ho tatuato anni fa qui
dietro le spalle un annetto fa circa ho
pubblicato un video parlando dei miei
tatuaggi vi ho spiegato il loro
significato ve li ho fatti vedere ma
tanti di voi non sapranno che ve ne ho
nascosto uno anzi due
sono due semplici parole ma insieme
parlano di me del periodo in cui l'ho
fatto un periodo in cui mi sentivo persa
fragile e circondata dal buio ma dal
buio si può sempre riemergere
basta avere la forza di lottare di
andare avanti basta non smettere mai di
credere nei propri sogni quando tatuato
quelle due parole una sulla spalla
destra e una sulla spalla sinistra ho
capito che ero pronto a lasciare il
passato alle spalle
ho deciso di diventare la migliore
versione di me ho deciso di far uscire
un po di luce quello che vi ho appena
letto è ciò che ho scritto sotto questa
foto in questo posto pubblicato il 24
gennaio su instagram
quando mi sono tatuata queste due parole
stavo appunto attraversando un periodo
abbastanza difficile complicato della
mia vita e nel momento stesso in cui lo
tatuate ho deciso mi sono imposta che da
quel momento in poi sarei diciamo tra
virgolette rinata grazie a questa
rinascita io sono qui ora nel senso che
non avendo più paura del giudizio degli
altri mi sono lasciata completamente
andare e essendo me stessa sono arrivata
fin qui da voi ho aperto il canale è
iniziata questa mia avventura
un'avventura è un percorso che non
avrebbe avuto un senso senza di voi
quindi visto che è tutto merito agosto
quello che abbiamo costruito in questi
anni ho deciso di creare qualcosa
che ci recasse per sempre qualcosa di
nostro queste due parole sono cuore e
corazza in una spalla scritto cuore
nell'altra corazza
sono emozionatissima è agitatissimo allo
stesso tempo e non vedevo l'ora di
potervi finalmente annunciare che cuore
corazza non è più soltanto un tatuaggio
ma è il titolo del mio primo romanzo non
potete capire quanto è stato difficile
non condividere tutte le emozioni tutti
i passaggi tutte le fasi con voi non
potete capire punto cruciale
ma di cosa parla questo romanzo allora
innanzitutto vi dico che non è
assolutamente una passeggiata a scrivere
un libro
anzi ci sono vari step varie fasi di
lavorazione e la più diciamo importante
quella decisiva e quando si pensa io
cosa vado a raccontare che storia posso
raccontare quali quale devono essere le
dinamiche della storia quali possono
essere i personaggi quali che mi voglio
andare a toccare per dare anche un
messaggio a chi legge questo libro ho
deciso di parlare di un periodo che
credo abbia segnato e segni un po
chiunque tutti noi
l'adolescenza la protagonista infatti di
questo romanzo non vi voglio spoilerare
troppo però è una ragazza liceale che
sta per iniziare l'ultimo anno di liceo
senza andare troppo nello specifico
quello che vi posso dire è che la
protagonista di questo romanzo come
tutti gli adolescenti deve affrontare le
sue insicurezze le sue paure i suoi
dubbi ma anche dei sogni e delle
passioni
quindi credo che tutti quanti si possano
identificare in lei marina ma questa
storia parla di te la storia che ho
scritto
ovviamente anche un po ispirata a quella
che è stata la mia esperienza la mia
adolescenza ma ci sono anche tante altre
cose che riguardano poi le vostre storie
che mi avete raccontato in questi anni
le vostre sicurezze le vostre paure le
vostre passioni
ho cercato insomma di mixare le due cose
scrivendo questa storia ho cercato di
alternare il più possibile quelle che
sono le due anime
quella scherzosa sbarazzina comica la
marina insomma che ama far ridere e
divertire gli altri ma anche quella
parte un po più riflessiva che ama
diffondere dei messaggi che riguardano
temi sociali importantissimi di cui
bisogna parlare chi mi segue lo sa che
ho diciamo utilizzato la mia popolarità
sui social terra appunto parlare di temi
sociali come la violenza sulle donne
il bullismo omofobia e qui dentro
troverete esattamente il riflesso della
marina che avete avuto modo di conoscere
in questi tre anni
basta spoiler che vi sto già dicendo
troppo non vi nascondo che è stato un
anno davvero intenso faticoso e duro ho
cercato di mettere tutta me stessa anima
e cuore per questo progetto ma non ho
assolutamente voluto trascurare la parte
dei video quindi ho curato il canale ho
avuto qui b day sempre contenuti nuovi
nonostante vi assicuro posti brevissima
da questo progetto quindi spero
tantissimo che apprezziate e soprattutto
vorrei che coloro che hanno insomma dei
pregiudizi per quanto riguarda i libri
degli youtuber mi dessero una piccola
possibilità perché vi assicuro che non
ne rimarrete delusi
potete già iniziare a preordinare cuore
corazza cliccando il link che vi lascio
qui sotto e nei box e dalle 12 di
febbraio lo troverete in tutte le
librerie
inutile dirvi che sono super emozionata
ma soprattutto che non vedo l'ora di
vedervi di abbracciarvi di incontrarvi
perché ovviamente una volta uscito il
libro ci saranno i firma copie e giro
per tutta l'italia quindi arriverò da
tutti voi ovviamente appena usciranno le
date del tour delle comunicherò mi
raccomando seguitemi su instagram perché
le comunicazioni e gli avvisi di solito
di pubblico cercherò di essere presente
anche qui su youtube ma per sicurezza
seguitemi
ricordatevi di lasciarvi un commentino
qui sotto facendo vi sapere insomma cosa
ne pensate se siete felici di questa
nostra nuova avventura e soprattutto
commentate con l'asta ufficiale cuore
corazza concludiamo questo video una
maniera un pochino diversa
di solito dico ci vediamo al prossimo
video e ci vedremo sicuramente al
prossimo video ma questa volta ci
vediamo anche di persona ai firma copie
di cuore corazza io non vedo l'ora
un bacione ci vediamo presto
[Musica]